Hey David, how will the 15% primary threshold
effect who wins the democratic primary?
So there's another way.
I think that what people are trying to get
to is, is the 15% threshold going to screw
this candidate or that candidate?
So there's a couple of things to understand.
In the democratic primaries, there is a 15%
threshold where if you don't get 15% of the
vote, you don't get any of the delegates.
This is particularly important in the bigger
States because in the smaller States, there
are often so few delegates to go around that
besides the, the sort of momentum impact of
it, it's not really mathematically that important
to be getting delegates from the small States
as long as you can continue justifying staying
in the race if, but if no candidate meets
the 15% threshold, what the democratic party
rules is that the minimum to receive delegates
becomes half of the front runners vote share.
So imagine that you have a state where a candidate
wins with 14% of the votes.
That's the plurality 14% and then you know,
someone else has 13 and 12 whatever it adds
up to a hundred if the winner has 14% everybody
would 7% or more delegates gets delegates.
So that's in the rules.
But let's put that aside for a second, cause
that's not the most likely scenario.
In later States, in really big States, you
could see this become a factor, uh, in the
broader delegate math.
So imagine that California goes the way one
recent national poll says, imagine that Biden
gets 23% of the vote in California.
Warren gets 18 and Bernie gets 14 hypothetically,
right?
Because Bernie didn't get 15% of the vote.
Bernie gets zero, which means that Biden gets
his 23% uh, Warren gets her 18% it actually
can go up once you eliminate people sub 15
but ignore that for now.
But the really important thing about this
is that Bernie and Warren in this scenario
have 32% a strong progressive contingent that
has more support than Biden, but that 15%
threshold could make it so that the progressive
candidates get kneecap and end up getting
zero in some States because one of them didn't
get to the 15% this is why I get emails from
people saying, David, at some point shouldn't
burn your Warren drop out because if they
make it so that neither or only one of them
gets 15% and the other ends up getting no
delegates as a result of that, isn't it going
to help the establishment?
Basically Joe Biden when the answer is yes,
but this is why it's good for the early primaries
to help one candidate build momentum over
the other.
My most, uh, the most likely scenario for
how this is going to go is that after New
Hampshire, uh, after, sorry, Iowa, New Hampshire,
Nevada and South Carolina, after they all
vote, I think there is going to be a clear,
a clear momentum advantage for either Bernie
or Warren as the progressive candidates.
And I think that in the end, the one with
the momentum is going to take a significant
lead over the one that doesn't have it.
And this issue of splitting the progressive
vote will be less and less of an issue as
the campaign goes forward.
I could be wrong and if that doesn't happen,
then it is possible that the progressive wing
of the democratic party will be hurt by this.
But my expectation is that the first four
primaries will establish which of the two
progressives is going to go the distance and
that then you will very quickly start to see
support coalescing around one or the other.
If you think it won't go that way, then I
want to hear from you.
Either leave a comment, if you're watching
on YouTube
or send me a tweet at D Pacman, we've got
a fantastic bonus show for you today with
producer Pat.
Become a member@joinpacmandotcomorapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidpakmanshowtogetinstantaccesstothatbonusshowthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible].